al hablar aquí en este
porque se van los niños las niñas
hondureña se van por dos razones
principalmente anteriormente los niños
se iban y la niñez se iba por la reunión
reunificación familiar y por este una
movilidad económica en este caso la
niñez hondureña está huyendo de la
violencia que existe en el país
actualmente en las principales 22
ciudades del país 500 barrios y colonias
se encuentran en poder del crimen
organizado hay una total ausencia de
estado entonces más que crisis
migratoria debería mar y hablar de
crisis de desplazamiento interno y
externo desplazamiento forzado en los
últimos 10 años en los últimos 10 años
58 mil 500 hogares han sido desplazados
de estos un 40 por ciento son niños y
niñas la gi para esto se está grabando
cada día más en el país y por ende vamos
vamos a ver un mayor flujo de gente
huyendo de honduras no es propiamente
hablar sólo de inmigración tenemos que
hablar de desplazamiento forzado por
violencia sin las consecuencias que
tienen que ocasionen los niños son
múltiples principalmente el ser
separados por su familia este y los
daños emocionales son múltiples
principalmente en que hemos atendido
niños en casa alianza con problemas de
ansiedad con problemas de miedo y lo
daño físico en algunos casos son gastos
irreversibles lamentable lo que nos está
contando y le pregunto entonces señor
flores desde su organización qué tipo de
ayudas ofrecen a los menores de edad y
también a sus familias bueno en la
organización en la que nosotros
trabajamos que ofrece
y albert es permanente que hay un
programa residencial atención a las
familias y tenemos un programa
especialmente en san pedro sula en el
departamento deportes para atender a la
niñez y a familias desplazadas por la
violencia este este fenómeno está
creciendo y es un fenómeno que no se le
pone la atención debida el gobierno
actualmente habla de que de que 247 mil
familias han sido desplazadas por
violencia las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil y diversas organizaciones
que trabajan en este tema hablan de
medio millón de personas al menos ahora
en su opinión que tiene que ocurrir en
los países del triángulo norte para que
esta situación se regularice un poco y
dejemos de ver esta huida y el
desplazamiento interno también como
usted no está comentando
en primer lugar el término triángulo
norte es un término que no me gusta usar
porque es el término que nos ha puesto
eeuu y con eso nos es en matiza cada
país que se estigmatiza es un país
problemático para ellos yo hablo de los
países del norte de centroamérica en
este caso que se debe hacer es cumplir
los estados deben cumplir y garantizar
los derechos de la niñez honduras por
ejemplo es el país que más viola los
derechos de las niñas y niños
actualmente son 800.000 niños este están
recibiendo cobertura educativa de 3.000
de 3 millones del tiempo 2000 que la
necesitan y estos 800.000 sólo 350.000
aprobaron su año su año lectivo
posteriormente en la última en la última
década han sido asesinados más de 300 de
13.500 niños niñas en el país por las
que hemos realizado entonces un país que
no puede garantizar los derechos de las
niñas éste va a tener que iba a seguir
profundizándose esta problemática
buscar mejores oportunidades o
garantizar su vida en otro aspecto señor
flores gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24
lamentable a la situación que se vive
con la niñez en honduras y también los
países de centroamérica